(audience cheers)
- We've got some fans.
- Just.
- We've got,
got a few fans.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- I mean, I swear to God,
I don't think like Harry Styles
gets that kind of entrance here.
That was amazing.
- Harry Styles doesn't hang
out in the parking lot.
- I love a good tailgate.
So I'm there.
Do you know Laura?
Have y'all ever met before?
- No, I thought I thought it was so cool,
the fact that,
we both said it's, it's nice to meet like
like see her,
like wow.
- Yeah.
It was like, so cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You're both very kind.
- Thank you.
- Yes.
- So wait, this is huge.
So you're the first
comedian to ever do standup
at Dodger Stadium.
First of all, I said to her
right before you came out,
I was like
doing Dodger Stad-
That's amazing.
You know how many people fit in there?
(audience applauds)
That's incredible.
Like, is this just like,
are you freaking out?
- It's, it's very surreal
because I've been to the
ballpark a million times.
Been going there since I was a kid.
And so the fact that
this show's gonna happen
it's like the biggest
thing I've ever done,
and it's at home.
- [Laura] Isn't that amazing?
- I know, that's so cool.
Do you get,
do you get excited about home crowds
or do you get nervous?
- I used to get really
nervous about home shows
cause then you know,
you get the phone calls,
"Hey man what's up?"
People I haven't heard from all year,
you know, necesito boletos.
I'm like, great
I gotta hook up tickets.
Right?
And so, you know,
and then just people coming out that
I haven't seen in a long time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Gabriel] So it's a
little extra pressure.
- Do you say ticketmaster.com?
- Nice.
- [Kelly] Do you send them there?
- You can't,
Well, first of all,
with Mexican families it's hard
because they guilt you.
- Yeah.
- It's something all the time, if I-
- I think you don't have to be Mexican.
All families will,
there's a level of guilt happening.
Yes.
- But they bring in
religion and your childhood.
- Ah, so do Southern Baptists.
- [Gabriel] Oh, okay. (both laugh)